Damien decides to give him some money to
a best so he gives him like 50 grand to
invest
yeah it's 50 grand to invest so he gives
him like 50 grand and blame basically
blows that money and so when Damien
comes back for the money he says he
convinces him listen let's open up a
business together we'll open up a forex
trading company we'll trade Forex it's
like a you know like a hedge fund or
something where you guys will invest and
we'll invest their money so I don't
quite know if Damien at that point knew
his money was gone or if he just kind of
joined him he very quickly realized this
money was gone because Damien
immediately turns around and starts
raising money well the guy that Damien
knows that has money is a guy named
Donovan Davis so he goes to Donovan and
he says hey Donna McDonald Ben's driving
a Porsche he's got a Lamborghini he's
got I mean you know he's got a Bentley
I'm how explain again how he has money
what his business does his money his
parents came here they started a company
eventually and it they buy and sell dirt
yeah okay so buy and sell they buy land
they dig it up they sell dirt I don't
think they're buying dirt so they're
selling dirt so they they are they
figures basically what they do is I
think all of Brevard County is like two
or three feet under under sea level so
to build on it you can't build on
anything that's not sea level so you
they'll sell you the dirt to build up
the land to build your house or build a
filter right filter that's smart you own
the real estate and you just mine it for
[ __ ] they don't need revenue bearing
them they don't even own the real estate
sister don't really what so you all you
have 40 acres they come in they say
we're gonna lease it for the next two
years and we're gonna dig out X amount
of dirt out of your land and when you're
done you're gonna have a bunch of a
bunch of huge ponds and you can turn
around you can sell it to us up and
create a subdivision now you get
basically have lakefront property Wow
and they go okay cool so they go and
they dig it pick a bit dig here dig here
dig here when you leave you're happy
they just now
it's a bunch of pawns so I got I got
this lakefront property I can have a
developer come in put it in the roads
that I could sell it off at that like
that they're happy cuz they'd be able to
sell that filled dirt yeah so
everybody's happy so that's what they do
and Donovan when he graduates high
school he's and he's always been working
on their I got pictures of him on my
website inside true-crime comm so
pictures of him and his brother working
on the working on excavators working on
tractors I mean little tiny kids are out
there so is they have a what what's that
that show the Gold Rush no show where
they have the big old railroad the
dredges yeah they've got a dredge dam
there's they're not [ __ ] around yeah
so he's been doing this his whole life
so he comes into the business he started
he starts working the business and he
said very quickly he ends up going into
the office and the business ends up just
booming like he really takes it from
being this business that's doing well to
really doing well I forget the number
what they how much it grew after he got
it and really started they were doing
like in the millions per month you said
right right whose it was it was a huge
amount of money so he's making a ton of
money
like I said Lamborghinis you see his
[ __ ] house man it's a mansion all
from selling dirt from selling dirt
that's nuts so he's doing great
Damien knows him the families know each
other Damien comes in and says look man
I'm starting this this Forex company
it's a we're doing management we're
during forex trading and we're gonna
take him can you you know you should
invest I'm telling you easiest money you
ever made I can make you a bunch of
money go to the website check it out so
Donovan does officially Donovan's dad's
like look you know he keeps hounding
Donovan he's like he's like look man
he's trying to start up a business
couldn't give him some money so Don he's
alright fine he gives him like 50 grand
well like a month later
Donovan's made like three or four grand
of fifty in a month he's like [ __ ] it
gives him another 50 he goes online he
checks and he checks it out and he's
like yeah look I made the money that
money is gone bro mm-hmm that money on
what that money went straight to Damien
and to um and to Blaine mm-hmm it's like
almost looks like a few thousand dollars
was actually put into any trades so he
gives another 50 grand
gone gives him a hundred grand then he
invites blent adamian to go talk to his
family donovan comes in and says man i'm
making a bunch of money I'm getting like
7% 8% a month that's like seventy
percent a year it's like no sorry it's
like 80 something eighty four percent a
year
[ __ ] I'm double to double my money
this is amazing yeah I might use yeah
and of course Damien say well I don't
know much about it but Blaine is is a
master trader he knows everything about
it
Blaine's a hit-or-miss guy I mean it's
difficult to make money in forex
so anyway next thing you know the his
aunt and uncle put in money his uh they
put somebody who is it put one oh his
best friend puts in like 50 grand they
put in another somebody else puts in
like a hundred somebody else puts in
fifty somebody else next you know he's
raised like half a million dollars from
his own family so and this is Aaron
Donovan's yeah it's great Damon yeah I'm
from the family so you know it's I think
it's called an infinity uh scam where
you go to your friends and family and
they become your first victims so they
make a bunch of money well then Donovan
gets invited to several of these uh of
these convince these uh like they're
like meetings where the people come in
and you try and get investors and you
sell they sell software trading software
and they sell different they talk about
different platforms and companies
calling a trade show like a trade show
but they also kind of teach classes on
it will Blaine's there and Blaine's
teaching the classes so when Donovan
gets there he's like [ __ ] this is the
guy this is your partner yeah man he's a
master trader well Donovan speaks with
several guys from like pfg is was the
biggest forex trading company that was
out there right there were also got
billion dollars or something outrageous
so he Donovan's they're talking with
these guys and these guys are like oh
this guy's amazing
this guy Blaine's phenomenal everybody
could say nothing but amazing things
about Blaine how wonderful he was so
Donovan's like wow well they keep they
keep raising money eventually they come
to
eventually they come to Donovan and they
say listen you know at this point
Donovan's put in I think two million and
his family put in like two million
dollars so they're doing pretty good
so Damien and Blaine are doing pretty
good so they come to Donovan they go
listen and you've helped us out so much
we're gonna give you what we're gonna
give you a third of the company for
$600,000 so you give us another 600,000
we're gonna give you a third of the
company and so he I just remember when
when we talked when he told me that the
first time he told me that he told me
the story he was yes oh yes oh they were
gonna give me a third of the company I
remember I go why here's what do you
mean I go why would they do that
yeah and he goes well you know cuz I'd
help them out I said right you gave him
two million dollars they're not making
the whole two million they're making a
small percentage on the trades yeah why
would they give you a third of the
companies well I was gonna give him
$600,000 let's get but they're doing
well
and they're just gonna continue to do
well and you're already raising the
money for no for nothing for free you're
already helping them introducing them
and all of these people are making money
so this thing's gonna spread very a
Ponzi scheme doesn't need a lot of
advertisement it spreads pretty quickly
because it's so phenomenal word-of-mouth
right so why do they need you I didn't
know I had I really knew nothing about
their about his story at this point
but instinctually I knew something's
wrong yeah no hand something over for
$600,000 that to me is worth gonna be
worth hundreds of millions right and he
got heels well I I yeah I don't know I
mean I gave him the six hundred thousand
and so yeah and I was like and he goes
yeah I mean he was it was it was a scam
and I go what do you mean he said was a
scam they they they came to him they
said give us six hundred thousand and
all you've got to do is raise money so
one I get you for six hundred thousand
more and you bring in and I bring you in
and give you an incentive to raise money
for me and so that's what he does he has
his his lawyer
look up the book do the paperwork his
lawyer does due diligence checks out the
whole model checks out everything checks
out both Damien and Anne Blaine and says
these guys are amazing this guy Blaine
is phenomenal this is a great business
opportunity by the way Blaine had been
arrested several times the lawyer still
couldn't he must how do they come up
with all that paperwork and stuff being
in it and suffer who the Damien in and
Blaine all this paperwork bank statement
that's it yeah he's got a he's an IT guy
yeah that's how he made that fake
website right we always got on the web
side he's got everything there listen
it's it's I could I could come up with a
couple with a dummy website that'll fool
you
so and this guy's got a degree so he
knows what he's doing
eat totally fine okay what ends up
happening is is Donovan puts in the
money he starts raising money and starts
raising a lot of money they get a big
office they've got they've got a bunch
of these this they got an office like it
it was in Naples one in a Melbourne
they've got there so they're kicking ass
they're raising money eventually this
guy by the name of Chris Roman daddy
comes in and and listen Blaine Blaine is
good ok he's he's very good at what he
does
and I'm an example that I use in here
the example is that that Blaine at one
point goes to Chicago so I'm pretty sure
Chicago so at one point Blaine goes to
Chicago and he's going to strip clubs
and he's blowing money the strip clubs
are actually outside of Chicago you have
to drive there they know I don't think
they they don't have any insight but
anyway so he's goes to the strip clubs
he's blowing money well one day after he
gets into a limo and the limo driver
female driver hears him bragging about
how he's blown like 20 grand or
something blew over 20 grand in the last
couple nights on strippers and she goes
what do you do for a living and he
says IIIi ona I'm a Forex trader and I
own part of a Forex company called
capital blue and they came with the name
Kappa that was the name of the company
Capital blue why they call it that um he
thought I won I don't know why it came
with capital blue but I do know that he
said blue BL you he knocked the e off
because he thought it made it sound more
trendy yeah I actually have that in a in
a in the thing they would they explained
they asked and he knocked the knee off
that the the e off because it sounded
blue now it's an e-cig company yeah so
he he so she hears him talking he talks
to her for five minutes
pictures are what he does she says I've
got she's I've saved twenty five
thousand dollars for my kids child for
my child's college fund she was maybe I
should give it to you something like he
is our minimum our minimum is like 40
grand or fifty grand place it was a
hundred in the story no and what does he
say us a hundred when audio but the
audio when you set me he said the
minimum is a hundred but I guess 100 no
no 100% he says yeah you write a hundred
thousand uh here's the minimum is a
hundred thousand he said but I like you
I'll take the twenty five thousand
that's [ __ ] just took her [ __ ] s
ruthless that's all and she Martha my
like a week later she watched the money
Donovan said he is I found out about
that at my sentencing that's first time
I ever heard that no no of course the
money just right to blame they're not
he's not trading it